but now that we've gotten the polling
part out of the way I want to dig into
questions have been receiving about
could this be brexit to point out over
the last couple of weeks there's been a
number of articles written there's been
a whole bunch of emails that I received
saying David Trump has been talking
about his election as brexit 2 point 0
and when I first heard that I said oh he
must mean that the election is going to
be yet another case in which the voters
make a huge mistake and elect him like
they voted to leave the European Union
that's not actually what our viewers
meant what our viewers were talking
about was in brexit there's this idea
and we'll figure out whether it's even
true you hear repeated very often that
all the polls said brexit was going to
lead to a vote to remain in the EU where
is on Election Day it was a huge shock
very different than the polls voters
selected chose to leave the EU I'm going
to push back against even that but let's
sort of talk it through Hillary Clinton
winning in the polls okay what if the
polls are wrong what if the polls as
Donald Trump has suggested are like
brexit where they said that a British
voters UK voters were going to vote to
stay in the EU but ended up actually
voting to leave Trump saying we will win
we will shock the world this is going to
be brexit plus well it doesn't match
what the polls say as I told you but
let's play it out right what if US
pollsters are just not polling shy
Republicans or what if pollsters are not
accounting for I don't know Trump's
ability to in the last few days before
the election inspire turnout in numbers
that nobody is figuring could happen
it's important to know a few different
things number one the brexit polling
that showed that remain was going to win
was barely outside the margin of error
so I know you've probably been hearing
oh the brexit polls were overwhelmingly
that they were there was going to be a
vote to remain and it was a total shock
because the results were so different
the polling just before the vote was
pretty close and it ended up 52 to 48 to
main nate silver has addressed this
let's take a look at this tweet where
nate silver said repeating myself but
the brexit polls weren't bad show to
toss up question is why so few people
believe them so number one the entire
brexit analogy is not particularly good
however this is a really good reason to
make sure that you go out and vote
rather than assume anything but brexit
is not an apples-to-apples comparison
there are some major differences which
suggests that we are not going to see a
brexit type and I hesitate to even say
that because we've debunked it but a
brexit type situation where Hillary
Clinton is leading almost every poll for
weeks and weeks and weeks and then on
Election Day Trump comes in and win now
there's a few reasons for this number
one is our voting system uh is is
different than what the brexit vote was
right brexit required a simple majority
of the popular vote you get fifty
percent plus one vote and you win period
we have an electoral college in the
united states and we have electoral
college votes and those are only
somewhat in proportion to the popular
vote as an example if you go back to
nineteen eighty four ronald reagan had
uh an overwhelming majority of the
electoral college right way way way more
than seventy eighty percent i don't even
remember the exact number but he had
fifty-eight percent of the popular vote
because he won i believe it was all
states but minnesota by a little bit so
even a small lead in the US in the
popular vote can translate to a major
win in electoral college that's number
one remember President Obama was 0.2%
ahead of Donald Trump nationally uh I'm
sorry in ahead of Mitt Romney came out
with a four percent win in the popular
vote but had nearly two-thirds of the
electoral vote so right off the bat Pat
I don't know that you can compare a
popular vote referendum with our system
of an electoral college and make any
analogy yeah I think that's fair and
also the polls how they are today aren't
necessarily how they're going to be a
couple weeks from now tour right on the
day of the election and before
or hand we also look sometimes at
election predictions like by nate
silver's 538 yeah and they usually say
Hillary is an eighty-five percent chance
well the fifteen percent chance that
Trump wins could still happen yeah what
that means is if you ran 100 elections
based on current state by state polling
and uh you know build in some additional
variance in terms of how things could
reasonably vary in certain states 85 out
of those hundred simulations Hillary
Clinton would win 15 out of those
hundred simulations Donald Trump would
win in 15 is still a lot right for a guy
who has no business being the Republican
nominee the other reason why I do not
believe we were going we are going to
see a quote brexit style polling uh up
set up is polarization most voters in
the united states are very reliably
republican or democratic voters so we
can say anybody could vote for anybody
on november eighth the reality is that
when you combine what we would call the
base party voters with our electoral
college system it can only really swing
to some degree and it would only be
enough to swing a few key states and at
a so called total surprise on election
day just isn't very likely the most
important thing to get from this is get
out and vote right not just for
president but down ballot because it is
it is uh unlikely that we are going to
see completely unpredictable upsets but
it is not impossible and that is the
message I'm going to be voting tomorrow
in Massachusetts on tomorrow's show I
will actually go through my ballot with
you item by item election by-election
question by question and talk through
what I'm going to be doing uh and we'll
review some interesting other ballot
questions across the country etc
whatever you believe to be the truth
about the polls this is the most
important possible thing I can tell you
don't say I'm not going to vote don't
say I'm going to stay home because I
think my candidate has lost don't say
I'm going to stay home because I think
my candidate has it one without my help
that for me Pat is the most important
message here in this election you just
go out and vote yeah fulfill your civic
obligation if you don't vote it rats the
help the Republicans
and we need a good turnout for this
election no doubt about it so we will
take a break we'll talk about early
voting later I know a lot of people want
me to address that we do actually have a
lot of voting already above 7 over 7
million votes cast already mine will be
one of them tomorrow we'll talk about
that later of course i'm on twitter at d
pakman today's program is brought to you
in part by frame bridge which lets you
custom frame whatever you want it is
super easy to use i used it last night
and actually uploaded a really cool
picture i took during my last trip to my
hometown of bonus itís in Argentina and
I uploaded it I was able to choose a
frame I was able to choose matting and
if you don't have the eye for this in
the way that I probably don't but
attempted to do anyway uh frame bridge
actually has a free design service where
their designers will help you to figure
out what frame and matting makes the
most sense for your picture the prices
start at $39 all shipping is free the
frames use premium real wood moldings
acid-free matte board and foam board and
their acrylic glazing will never shatter
and it also will protect your piece from
harmful UV rays if you can't upload what
you want to frame if it's a physical
item or something you already have
printed or a jersey you can mail it in
and then frame bridge will get it framed
mounted and sent back to you ready to
hang with everything you need we have a
promo code if you go to frame bridge
dot-com and use the promo code maybe not
surprisingly Packman PA que ma n you
will save an extra fifteen percent off
of your first order that's frame bridge
com use the promo code Packman PA que ma
n and you will get very very cool custom
framed art for your place